[Musique]
voilà tout ce qui joue sur la on a
quelqu'un en ligne qui va jouer avec
nous allô allô allô allô allô typos allô
allô oui qui est un appareil
bonjour laura comment ça va tu nous
appelles doubs alors attends tu nous
appelles ou la loire-atlantique loire
atlantique
tu passe sous un tunnel mais tous
exactement laura comment tu habites où
exactement leur as tu parles un petit
peu français
oui oui t'as beytout matière y en aura
non mais où est localisé savez très bien
où ça chiant loyrette
la plus je me bats
à part
[Rires]
j'ai mes limites
j'aimais nous l'écouté je connais la
france vers je m'en vais je me casse je
me casse au cadre de l'émission
par émission mais trois fois comme lille
aura dans le bon soir monsieur
le projet trouver quelqu un m paraît
sauvé quelqu'un c'est vrai tu peux me
manque pas et moi loin tout au plus
chaud au bout du rouleau tu peux merci
mais moi le casque merci on se casse on
se casse en chine j'en ai marre salut ça
va mon cv
[Applaudissements]
merci